So now that we have this equation for the
total amount of money that Grant's going
to make from people who bought his
products the first day and the second day,
it would be great if we could simplify it
further, however we don't know how to do
that yet. So, before we dive into this
particular example, let's look at a
slightly less complicated but similar
problem. Let's say we just have some
expression. I picked 3x - 5y + 6x + 9y.
Now how can we simplify this expression?
Well, I think we need to remember what
each of these terms really means. So 3x
for example is actually equal to x + x + x
and 6x is actually equal to 6 x's added
together. Right now, writing this out
might not seem particularly helpful. But I
think the reason that I chose to write
these terms this way will becomes clear if
we just rearrange the order of the terms
in this expression. So now we switch the
order of the terms around so that terms
with x are next to each other and the
terms of y are next to each other. Now we
can see that the first thing we want to do
is add 3x and 6x together. With all of the
x's written out, that doesn't seem that
hard. I just need to figure out how many
x's, total I have down here. And if I
count them I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 9 x's. So I guess that means that 3x +
6x = 9x. Now, one thing we can notice is
that, in order to get the sum of 3x and 6x
here We don't actually have to count all
the x's. All we really have to do is add
the coefficients of the variables
together, since 3 + 6 = 9. Once we have
the coefficient, we just make sure that we
multiply that by the variable that both of
these terms have. We usually call this
adding like terms, or combining like
terms, as I've written at the top of the slide.